guess we serve Oh worry I can't see you
never see me I could see your car you
have to catch said you better catch me
sab sab you got me if he got me I said
he didn't have me
campus what wanna be your is that no no
I just I was just being sick you know I
had some ideas about a gang sign no no I
I was wondering if I could be your night
nurse that's what the song sir said is
this wait a minute is this cuz it's
valentine's Day is this your attempt to
robot you literally brought me under the
bridge down to do this save on
Valentine's Day I'm not having
Valentine's Day and I gotta Thursday
this is this pathetic man ok yeah theres
a river whatever kind of if this takes
going all wrong it is Nate's gone you're
wrong you brought me to a terrible voice
the most romantic spot in Los Santos we
all go away and where I'll go and find
you the perfect Valentine's gift okay I
can go and find me perfect Valentine's
oh okay sure I think I bet I can beat
you this and then we can present our
gifts at the most romantic spots in Los
Santos may the best man win and they
also love win yeah you're a technique
looks a bit it is a rare but probably
just as sad as know what has been more
aggressive I said scared yeah somebody
so I think that was the worst day ever
second like cod or on the wall with the
worst day ever what suitable gift we set
for it maybe your car oh god no it
didn't all right I gotta take you a
series of photographs perhaps maybe that
maybe that all there were you suitably
oh oh god oh no I'm not strictly sure
love love is killed me say
I'm just currently cleaning myself
before I can find your gift properly the
cops are not accepting our love serve
their nah dude you know I just don't
understand you just don't understand oh
oh I think I may have found the first
part of your gift whoa don't keep your
feet up yes good good now can I steal
this book for you hahaha just dived onto
a boat are now dead a beer lovers clade
me once again so I love you vile
mistress how do I dumped my load camp
left so I have no idea oh don't jump out
so I'm pretty confident than my my
package is gonna win this one here your
packages can yeah my date package I mean
obviously really were you thinking about
your package oh oh love's love's arrives
loves arrives love loves [ __ ] off
come back my love I don't think the cops
will see me it's getting kind of violent
up in here oh good oh I'm dead my gift
to you I have a horrible feeling Maeve
to Spanish oh no I mean it's always the
same way you save every time same line
ah the gift is vanished into oblivion
Yeah Yeah right yeah what a gift it was
my dump truck full of women what what is
a good valentines gift Oh
I really need to do so what are you do i
went to back out of a thing i feel like
every button is assault and i need
something for a friend of mine we have a
very complicated relationship alright so
are you ready for our moonlit date oh
yeah the moon is out look at it now I
said meet at the tower didn't I the
construction site because we to build
our love said live it up the ground up
can we right here at the top let's begin
our date at the bottom of guitar one
condition yeah yeah you have to catch me
okay catch me serve oh where are you I
can't see you know see me I can see your
car you have to catch tell you better
catch be sad Sam be if you got me if he
got me I said he didn't have me I
thought I had sad ah little that love
blood no got it mm-hmm it's okay I'll
just bathe in it so right i had another
guy bought you a car what you bought me
a car yeah in your favorite colors pink
mixed with orange oh how did you know
yellow rim look at those tires yet so
you're gonna take me oh wow okay can you
break down the fence of love I'm no no
you can't restrain made of adamantium or
something the wolves that restraint i
love of a vicious and strong quick up
the ladder of love sev hub in the name
of love I can't help climbing to the
roof with you I'll of us are I want to
know what love is well I could probably
show you that that would be good the
power of love is actually a pretty
curious thing yeah nice nice red light
I've got sirens it's for you now Oh
gifts yeah give me gifts are you humming
okay pretty important oh are you smoking
hey now you never buy wait I thought
where's my gift this just you smoking I
dropped you on and I just threw it off
the side oh I just held it off the edge
okay you brought me up here to throw my
gift away so I've got a different gift
for you hold still I'll tear I don't
know if it means i can pick him up i'm
just throwing them on the ground to
stuffing them over the edge like hurling
all go fetch this is all states over
this dates over by States Danza
from he know it's over oh I'm really
sorry turns out the heat I don't have a
parachute no sir oh god no [ __ ] game get
out class a game class game how to hunt
guide me guys the treasure hunt it's
right yes Oh date time I have a date for
us okay this is where we start our date
then we come I'm to under scrutiny I'm
really honest music this is really
exclusive all right don't panic sir no I
would never panic we could be anywhere
in the world so with a view like that he
could be we can notice America I wanted
we r you by expressing my artistic side
oh okay first off I want to welcome you
to my parts ha ok to the day I'll give
it to tonight's date I'd also it's it to
my heart ok ok at the rain the rain
expresses sorrow oh it may be the rain
could express the fact that my heart is
melting ah would I let you inside where
that would mean I felt these looked a
bit like boobs that's pretty cool so I
thought you I thought you get on board
with that yeah yeah I'll get at you
because I will ah this date will not be
a courting disaster no light the fire
within your heart fire that burns in my
loins yes we're almost there and yeah
finally a photo of me and my junk pretty
move any that's pretty good yeah is that
it oh no on a close-up of the junkies
weapon you always need a closer closer
up yet bringing you to the most premium
spa in the hole in the whole of waiting
going the whole of Los Santos hot shave
a little bit of subtle makeup you have
to really make the eyes and lips pop
beautiful hmm the wet weather might mmm
effect and frizz up your hair just touch
me don't worry let's get back in the
vehicle where it's nice and dry so step
you see you know a place where we can
get crunk right oh oh I know place okay
okay he's just a classy joint yeah it's
pretty close Peppa joint I could take
you know my mother she want to come
along and find out okay he says this is
exactly like a real date I once went on
you can uh oh this is like everyday i I
don't I don't have enough cash for a
drink are you getting a bit drunk loud
you don't think
enough no no no it easy this is my
Valentine's Day two I don't want you to
embarrass me on our date I you don't
shut up so I just had leaned on this bar
I know what I want in a date and you
know I feel like we got it after we got
it you know like there was there was
adventure my spoon there was
misadventure yeah we spent some money
did some of us got some face paint yeah
and everybody got laid I get what it's a
wonder of both single cell you know what
like there's a lot of things in Los
Santos there's a lot of cars yeah it's a
lot of crime hmm there's not a lot of
love o'sheas school baby I know this
guy's gonna comfort knowing Star happy
it's alright it's just love just love
hunter it's just love son he doesn't
understand our love run don't run he
chased he go God we're friends it was
out you gonna stand for that oh god oh
god ty didn't you gonna let him hit your
date in that way a gang no dick oh that
was for not standing up from me it's
good it's good Oh finally sad I've been
waiting for one of these for ages you
normally never give me one so i
appreciate but i understand though why
you dropped them after two jars they're
really disgusting early they're just
just awful I there just after the first
two drags that really get with nothing
live say me happy Valentine's Day
Valentine's Days her Valentine's Day pal
you